when there is no required meaning and a  lot of language changes which is should  must need have to all of these things no  longer exist because there is no capital  M meaning so I don't should have to must  need to anything a lot of the  expectations that bury ourselves into  that weigh us down are just implied  shoulds have to's must and so if all of  those disappeared then in a lot of ways  it's very liberating in business it  allows me to take actions even though I  know that I shouldn't or must not or  other people would judge me for not  doing it the way that they thought I  should do it because there are no rules  we can live our life whatever way we  want to live and that's okay